I think for so many people that are
young they don't realize there's so much
even if it's just the office job still
there's so much opportunity because the
world treats you differently when you're
19 and I've come from somewhere else
right but then after maybe even mid-20s
it just changes because it's not seen as
like the young aunjanue right so is it a
process you think a lot of people once
they stay in this town they began to
realize and change themselves absolutely
III think I call it the LA machine you
cannot or the Hollywood machine no one
escapes it you know no one escapes it
everybody goes through the same exact
thing it's the same exact story it's
like when we spoke about my big breaking
about you know all of us actors living
in that one house together now it's some
other young actors and and and and that
are coming to town and so it's like
everybody has the same story just tells
it differently everybody has the same
obstacles in this town maybe just a
little bit different you know is where
you know my story was about my looks and
y'all wasn't good-looking enough or or
you know he's not a leading man you know
and then I had my buddy he was very very
good-looking and getting the complete
opposite well you're too good-looking oh
like what do you guys want you know so
you put up with a lot of that in this
industry and it's tough it's tough you
know no one wants to hear exactly how
you look you know at the saw this this
industry is very honest and and and now
at 40 years old I Know Who I am I know
where I fit and I'm okay with playing a
computer geek whereas before you know
when I was young I took it personally I
took it very personally because in my
mind I thought I was Leonardo DiCaprio
maybe that was a little bit of a
delusion in myself but that's how I had
to see myself in order just to like do
it and then I started getting all this
computer geek roles and I'm like but I'm
not I'm not a I'm not that guy and then
over time I'd realized well that's my
wheelhouse
and that's those are the roles that are
coming towards my way and
and now I embrace everything you know
it's not about being a leading man and
about being this particular actor it's
about being you and a being and and
knowing what you bring to the table what
you're good at and I feel like I've
after all this time realized you know
what I am good at and and looking
forward to being challenged now that I'm
40 and grown into myself I I'm looking
for that next next challenge are you
okay with being a sexy paranormal and
again you know no you know when people
ask me what I do I say I'm an actor and
I'm a paranormal investigator it says to
two things that I take very seriously
and and it's worked out it's worked out
in both realms so realms so I feel very
fortunate to be where I'm at and to have
worked like I have and like we talked
about it doesn't happen for everybody
and it's scary well I mean not everybody
has the ability to like themselves or
love themselves because of some label
whether it's even true or not that
someone else and power has put on them
right have you been able to come to that
place and what advice do you have for
other people I mean just as a woman I
know there's so much pressure whether
it's looks--wait
whether you're married or not yeah and
and I think a lot of women don't love
themselves I'm sure it's interesting to
hear that men go through it - yeah
that's it's kind of a shocker for me I
didn't realize it but how do you come to
terms with loving yourself no matter
what the label is someone puts on you
what even if it's not true the label
they're putting on I think it's tough I
think it's I think it's tough the number
one thing hard thing to do is to love
yourself I think I think I think we need
to learn at a young age maybe you know
we really need to practice it loving
ourselves and not you know pointing the
finger at ourselves and saying you know
you did this wrong and you did this
wrong because we have plenty of people
saying that in this town
so I don't know I think it's a daily
work
I think it's daily work because I have
those days where I'm like ah you know
you were terrible and then you have
those days really like you were amazing
you know so it's a daily work and I
think it's not just for women I think
it's for men too I think I think we're
all insecure in this town to some degree
in a little bit you know and it's how do
we deal with that how do we try to fill
ourselves up with something positive I
noticed too it seems like there's either
total self-hatred of oneself in this
town or total self-love there's very
little gray area right it's so true it
is it's it is true and there's a lot of
self-hatred or there's a lot of like way
too much self-love and going on you know
and I'm you're like okay come back down
everybody else
um yeah you're right there is no
in-between and I think if we can find a
way to sort of be in that in-between and
have a healthy ego as well as loving
ourselves I think that's a good
combination to have
you